what's the closest you can get within
the rules and the rules are you're
allowed to add numbers together you're
allowed to subtract numbers you're
allowed to multiply numbers and you're
allowed to divide numbers you're allowed
to have powers but I'm actually not
using those because when you're writing
a program to do it they explode you get
these ridiculously big values and it's
just easier to not bother but they are
allowed I'm just not gonna use them and
you're allowed to put brackets in to
choose the order so I'm going to put
some brackets there to symbolize that
and you're allowed to just bunch the
numbers together so if you look here
concatenation there you go well done
there you go see they were you're going
to have a concatenation theme today in
fact you could take these two videos
that involve concatenation and just play
them one after the other and so you
didn't bat an eye when three four five
six I do like what hang on you didn't
think well what's the mathematical
operation you've done there to put them
in order
you're just perfectly happy that of
course three four five six can be there
and so concatenations a strange one
there's no agreed symbol for
concatenation some people use two lines
some people use a plus in a circle some
people use like little dashes or dots or
all sorts of things I'm going to use I
tend to use the two lines right in it to
be complete I probably should have put
in this victory if we go back to the
past to fix previous errors if I was
being more thorough I would have put
three concatenate for concatenate five
concatenate six and down here I should
have done four concatenate three right
you know to be more thorough
so that is concatenation is clearly
allowed if we just for some reason we
never bother spelling it out so what I'm
gonna do is here's my almost but not
good enough attempt so it's gonna be a
Parker Square this is really cool right
so you start with twelve so one
concatenate two to twelve then times
three times four divide that by five
multiplied it by six multiply it by
seven add on eight put that whole thing
in brackets and then multiply that
by nine okay so what does this equal
let's check that with exactly if it
equals ten nine five eight we are on so
here we go
so one concatenate two that's 12 times 3
times 4 divided by 5 times 6 times 7
equals okay so that's the whole thing
there plus 8 equals 1200 seventeen point
six times nine equals ten thousand nine
hundred and fifty eight point four this
come on that's that's not bad
ten thousand nine hundred if you say
classic pocket square you're in so much
trouble Brady come on that's not bad
right that's as close as I can get
within the rules as initially I
understood them met in what world do you
think I'm not putting back a square on
the screen right now okay that is
unnecessary right okay anyway so as long
as you don't try to sell the t-shirt
again but do you know how many people
shop to my shows wearing parker square
t-shirts unbelievable right anyway so
what's interesting about the
concatenation thing is it's never
explicitly stated so if you ever look at
the start of the paper he talks a lot
about he loves plus product potentiation
to powers and brackets loves those he
will concede you can add in minus and
division which you like the second
they're not as good as plus and
multiplication or product but they're
okay and they're allowed it he never
explicitly says concatenation all he
does is in here he goes you can add a
and b multiply a and b powers of a and b
oh and of course i am be forming a
number so all the ones in here a lot of
them do use concatenation right from the
beginning it's never assumed you can't
do that but it's never used as a step
during the calculation it's only used in
a set up of the numbers that you then
apply the other operations to and I was
like that's a bit arbitrary it should be
a fully-fledged function if you go
include it you've got to include it and
so I found one times two concatenated
with three plus in brackets
four times five times six and then that
so four times five just you know we're
going with this that's going to be 20
times six is 120
but then 120 is concatenated with seven
so now you do the calculation first and
then you concatenate with another digit
then you add on an eight and that whole
thing you multiply by nine
shall we check it let's just do this
simplify it so they're equals okay one
times twenty three that's just twenty
three I think we're all quite happy with
that plus in brackets that's going to be
four times five is 20 times 6 is 120
concatenate with seven and then we're
gonna add on eight and then we're going
to multiply that by nine so now we've
got 23 plus 1 2 if I want to do this all
at once actually you know I'll do that
step there there's a concatenation plus
8 and then that there's multiplies by 9
ok so let's let's so we took that into
the calculator now that feels like it's
obvious enough that we can we can drive
this home one two zero seven plus eight
equals unsurprisingly 1215 times nine
equals that plus the 23 at the top
equals 10,000 958 there it is so we have
filled the gap because the gap was only
there because people weren't taking
concatenations seriously and I have I've
taken it seriously I've filled the gap
and I'm gonna send it in I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'll be like I think I fill the
gap it is it is now available really
that's the only reason I found this by
the way is because I wasn't afraid to
try something where the odds are I was
gonna fail miserably and I think that is
the moral of the Parker square right you
give it a go even though it's probably
not gonna work and you embrace it you
own it when it doesn't work every now
and then it does work out for you
times that bass had we worked out the
length or something well you use a log
right so it's log base whatever the
basis of your next digit